qui est derrière le rideau regardez qui
veut vous parler ce soir tard mokhtar ça
va il allait enfin oktar ce soir une
personne très spéciale est venu sur ce
plateau pour vous annoncer quelque chose
d'important
cette personne a n'ai jamais encore venu
dans notre émission c'est un peu une
séquence y'a que la vérité qui compte
vous rappeler de cette émission de tf1
présenté par pascal bataille et laurent
fontaine et bien je vous le dis il y a
des torrents d'émotion qui ont été
déversées dans cette émission sur tf1
et bien je peux vous dire que ce soir on
va tous être trempé comme isabelle vous
parlez de du happening et bien cirées
parce que la personne qui est derrière
le rideau est ici pour parler à mokhtar
mokhtar cayla qui est installé mokhtar
vous avez une idée de qui se cache
derrière le rideau non vraiment pas ce
que pouvait parler plus fort ce que je
ne vous entends pas non vraiment pas pas
ce petit tour la moto
pensez vous à une personne que vous avez
totalement perdus de vue
perdus de vue oui c'est à dire pas vu
depuis longtemps
je peux vous poser une question mais
maintenant quel réseau pourquoi y'a
toujours un casque enfin quand je suis
devant les yeux c'est toujours mieux
maintenant au cas où il prend l'avion
j'adorais regarder le cash est ce que il
ya quelqu'un qui a quelque chose à vous
reprocher mokhtar non ma femme
[Applaudissements]
alors aux motards il ya un premier
indice écoutez et regardez chez vous qui
va peut-être vous mettre sur la voie de
qui est cette personne regarde mokhtar
que penses tu du dicton tunisien une
seule babou je vous manque et tout est
dépeuplé commence à avoir une idée
mokhtar ou pas non aux pasdaran ont fait
ça n'ont pas pour l'instant
non non vous être qui je veux parler ou
pas du tout n'entend pas notre indice il
ya un deuxième indice écouter bonjour me
tard tu as dit que le rugby était la
deuxième famille mais pourrais-tu tout
plaquer pour la première avoir esprits
commençaient à y voir plus clair
un petit peu re penser à qui ma mère
octave tous voulaient enlever le le cash
avions
oct à ce que vous voulez voir qui se
cache derrière le rythme oui
là je peux vous dire je matte à côté de
mon mokhtar mokhtar on va vous montrer
tout de suite qui est derrière le rideau
regardez qui veut vous parler ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'auteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là
ces bons plats aux motards bon dos car
au nom car c'est parce que ta maman
asséné merci d'être là on a tous les
miens mais la maman de mokhtar de
tunisie et elle a quelque chose à dire à
mokhtar oui mokhtar je veux ni
aujourd'hui esprits et pauvres parce que
je t'aime beaucoup et je vais voir mon
petit fils aussi et je voyais n'est pas
venu seul ce soir à bogota
oui elle a une surprise pour pour
mokhtar ce soir je pense que ça va lui
faire très très plaisir on voulait le
faire une surprise déjà qui va partir à
las vegas déjà il va être comme un fou
je vous dis vous pouvez bien avec nous à
la moctar ouane a pourtant ce qu il n y
avait qu à las vegas l'apathie
mokhtar mokhtar et ya une surprise que
tu as fait ça ta maman ce soir est-ce
que tu étais content de l'avoir parce
qu'elle est en tunisie et comment vous
pas vu pour dormir à la maison soit
mokhtar vous êtes venu avec qui je
venais avec le 5 mai c'est donc fatiha
elle est venue avec mes soeurs jumelles
mais des gros soeur jumelle j'ai pas vu
depuis deux trois ans avec les soeurs
jumelles de votre part qui l'a pas vu
depuis trois ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'attends le motard un petit peu à
montreuil roches noires est et ça fait
trois ans que tu les as pas vu tes
soeurs et quoi et tu te dis va te des
soeurs jumelles comme ça ça fait comment
at on pu l'être a dû trois ans pour vous
le regardez pas la télé au petit bijou
rouler tous les jours et il est
formidable oui c'est un cadeau que je
voulais te faire présenter ce soir elles
sont venues voilà te voir de tunisie
elles vont rester avec toi elles vont te
bichonner maman va rester la rage de mam
après nous on s'en occupera l'eau mais
mokhtar illustrer leur porte-voix
exploite la mano river la matière
fatiha et mocquard est vraiment je suis
très heureux que sur l'évier merci je
crois que c'est une magnifique surprise
provoque tard voilà mon chéri et ben on
voulait faire la surprise en tunisie
c'est elle qui reste
mais si tu veux vous allez tous c'est
pour moi c'est cadeau je vous ai regardé
l'hippopotamus juste
[Applaudissements]